the Julian we're here today to talk
about your latest work which is in the
scottsboro boys now tell me a little bit
about the musical and your part in it
well the musical is suppose about the
most serious subject for musical I can
think of very briefly it's about nine
young chaps who were taken off a train
in 1931 in south south south of America
in Alabama and accused of raping two
white girls and which they didn't do but
they were accused of that and because of
the situation the racial situation in
the south which still goes on but not as
bad as it was then they are accused of
this terrible crime and they go through
finally about 8-9 trials and and they
disappear into the ether in the end I
mean it's a but it caused a tremendous
sir the time as you can understand the
whole of the rest of America
particularly in North America New York
and Chicago Washington all those places
seats of government made a tremendous
fuss about it first of all they were
going to hang them without trial and it
was as simple as that but they couldn't
do that and then they had a the first
trial the defense floor i was completely
drunk and put up no defense at all and
so they had to have a proper trial and
they did duck i make a musical out of
that if he can make a musical out of
that and you can well Kander and ebb you
know the great great team of chicago
producers indian have done this with the
help of Susan Stroman this fantastic
director and choreographer as they made
for my money one of the most wonderful
pieces of theatre I could possibly
imagine to be involved in and unless I
screw up because I'm the only real new
boy really it's going to be fantastic i
can pawn from confidently predict it's
going to be found
dick I am my parties like a sort of like
a ringmaster in a circus I hold the
thing together and play various parts
within it and quite a lot of the others
do too it's an all-black cast except for
me and I'm privileged to be part of it
really am now what's it like I said
you're the only new boy on the block
what's it like being the new kid on the
block and also what's it what's it like
you know you talk to me before we
started and you said you it's really
exciting the rehearsal poker process why
is it so exciting well because you know
I'm not known for doing the sorts of
things all my line of villains and all
that minding my parts were got a bit
softer than that in the last 20 years
anyway musicals something which foreign
to me really except i did do four years
ago i did i was in oliver with the
theatre royal drury lane and that was
very excited with Rowan Atkinson but
that was a straight acting part there
was no singing in it and certainly no
dancing where's at this time I sing my
lord and I'd have dance but I have to
move to music and it's as you must know
it's very very precisely the work you
have to do in that that sort of
precision I've never had to do before
and I'm really relishing it it's good
I'm finding it very difficult cuz I'm
such a state old bugger but when I get
it right it's just it's such a delight
when you actually click in in it piece
of the jigsaw goes into the puzzle oh
yeah the picture gets bigger and so I'm
very excited and and very pleased to be
doing it so Julian did you know anything
at all about the Scottsboro Boys is tale
before the musical came along absolutely
not I mean it's not part of
the British history it's part of the
American history all people of a certain
age / they will know what you mean when
you say the scottsboro boys younger
people not so much now because this
racial situation has changed its ease
their question but as I mentioned before
is still there and if you read books
like the help oversee the film the help
where I know that is now but it was at
the beginning of the fifties the
situation is still not satisfactory
though it is much better but English
people have not heard of this tremendous
but it was the beginning of the the
civil rights movement as we know it now
it was and it was what caused the
stopping of the all-white juries in the
South all-white juries there's no
argument and so a colored person stood
no chance we all know to kill a
mockingbird when but that was that was a
very very rare sort of event you know
stand up your father's coming by in that
rocking bird it that sort of compassion
wasn't around then and even people who
were in the scottsboro boys who were
compassionate people came down from New
York you discover that they all had
colored servants a colored chauffeurs
and maids and cooks and all that stuff
and thank god that's gone now but we we
don't know about it so I didn't know
anything about it at all until my agent
saw it in New York and said this is
wonderful musical in New York I think
you're very right for the part of
whatever it is I said well what is it
and he told me the story oh wow I've got
to be part of this she said it's not
story that some people are aware of
necessarily in the UK how do you think
they're for UK audiences will respond to
the scottsboro boys when it opens well I
think I think they'll respond even
better that needed in America because we
don't have any of those hang-ups they
have and I I predict that it well
probably wrong when if I never write in
the theater that it would be a great
success and audiences will take it to
their hearts and go oh wow of course we
know you so much not only for your
theater work as well but for your film
and TV work but what is it about theatre
treading the boards in particular that
you enjoy this is what I came in to do
these days is quite different when I
started we went it you went into the
theater that's what you did he's got a
television well who was it very exciting
but it wasn't really done in those days
and um certainly there made commercials
good god it's the film's you were lucky
and when I first went to Stratford in
1957 as a walk-on actor all the great
actors went to Stratford to to practice
their craft and that's what I came in to
do and so obviously it's my first love
and I mean all actors will tell you that
he is the fact that you've got a contact
with your audience and it's only going
to be like that for that night that the
next night it might seem to be the same
but it didn't so it's always a movable
feasts as it is when I meet you for the
second time that very nice to meet you
for the second time but it'll be a
different experience and that's what
happens in the theater and that's what's
so exciting and when you work in
theaters like I don't know the globe
theatre when I played King Lear without
their there and you're doing this
fantastic stuff it's it's internally and
externally really stimulating and the
Young Vic is a perfect theatre for that
audience communication thing and I've
seen many shows there and so is the old
Rick of course but in a different way
the Old Vic just happens to be a
extraordinary comfortable building I
don't know why it is but it just is the
Young Vic has been constructed in order
to be accessible and that's exactly what
it is is perfect for this show that
efficient and finally Julian why should
people come to see the scottsboro boys
when it opens
October well primary to enjoy themselves
it is an hour and a half of complete
enjoyment and you won't feel guilty
about enjoying ourselves at the
spectacle of these wonderful people
dancing and singing and the quality of
the music which is so high and and the
lyrics which is simply brilliant you
won't feel guilty about it because it's
such a serious subject yeah if you come
out of crazy for you and you've had a
really be single I shouldn't have
enjoyed that really but i did because
it's stimulating and titillating but
scottsboro boys you'll come out feeling
very moved very moved and that you've
had an hour and a half stimulating
entertainment no interval just goes it
drives through from the beginning to the
end I'm very much looking forward to
seeing it and enjoy the rest of
rehearsal thank you very much indeed
been pleasure talking
you